bom para você
e faz com prisão
eu vou fazer transferência está
acontecendo que deve ser feliz até que
mudará para sempre a história do mundo
é assim mesmo dia onze de setembro
nasceu minha filha é fala
o grupo de uma série de servir
em uma palavra
é mas aí
e ainda
o brasil todo
e aí
o braço
o google não tivesse falando assim pai
uma pessoa mais legal que eu conheço
minha filha tudo bem que for preciso até
esse momento
é mas você foi para ressonância eu já
sabia que ajudando lógico mas eu tô com
saudade do que isso foi
o seu compromisso muito grande
o possível e o impossível para casamento
eu vou contar uma situação como essa fio
minha filha sem problema neurológico se
você tem que entender que você faça uma
coisa ruim
e aí
a 200 livros
[Música]
e aí
e os meus tratamentos você tirou esse
tratamento que estava 49ers
e aí
e eu não falo para tu
e aí você quer dizer o suficiente para
levar é suave
e também com células-tronco
o site meus pais frango
e aí
[Música]
e essas coisas não
um mercadinho na mesma rua em
oi gente trocar business que eu ia só
mais um
é preciso
aí eu fui perguntei da minha filha
a pagar com 50reais a coisa que foi para
escola para ficar comigo
o brasil que dá certo você tem que ver
isso
eu vou morreu o carnaval
a novela a rolar eu gosto de futebol eu
fui bater na porta dos dias mais comigo
eu consegui acontecer dois grandes o
náutico santa cruz a fazer jogo conhecer
eles fizeram a coletiva de imprensa
nesse dia
e aí
e como funciona mais três todas as
jogadas isso
[Música]
a foto
e aí
em casa
tu já foi fazer o quê
o parque funciona a foto
[Música]
bom dia
e aí
[Música]
o nosso trabalho
e aí
é uma
[Música]
o que faz de bom aí
tu vai para missa
e aí
oi e aí eu consegui sobre os seus aqui ó
um trabalho de
e aí
e tu vai ver
e sabe da melhor
e aí
eu não consigo fazer fora do brasil
diversas metodologias inovadoras
e aí
[Música]
o restaurante é
e aí
a pessoa com ela muito calor com você e
não consegue ver que preciso
e aí
o youtube
é só cartuchos publicar publicar para
vestido azul cartão
e aí
e as pessoas estão
[Música]
e aí
bom dia
se consultar co
e aí
o alibaba.com
e vocês estão
eu chegar em casa tudo isso causa duas
vai aprender a programar para fazer
o que foi
e aí
o problema com as pessoas que temos um
há um ano
ah tá fazendo um pãozinho só
e aí
o fatos
a cada dia que passa o pai é
e aí
a permissão de
o que você quer saber
eu vou usar a peste lugares agora
concluir
[Música]
é já hoje volta a fazer países com
e você fala é uma foto aqui que é
e aí
e do norte
eu vou colocar aqui uma coisa
e aí
a organização disciplinar sucesso
é melhor ficar social usado
eu moro no próximo vídeo com tecnologia
do maior para 2014 e 2016
e aí
o consórcio de empresas do mundo
tô falando com ela e
e fica assim agora também esse cartaz
tá muito parado
e aí
é mas ela acabou de falar já ia te
perguntar se eu vou aí
e aí
[Música]
o desejo dela
e aí
eu estava com você agora
o resultado fosse
e aí
a aceitar mas você pode contar comigo
que eu vou ter
e aí
[Música]
é ele que vai falar
e aí
oi google oi
a foto
e aí
a empresa google
é uma situação de casa é
e aí
a pergunta para você